Hi!
My name is Vaibhav, and today we will learn
about functions.
Functions are very important concept, both
for your engineering entrance exams and also
to understand various concepts in mathematics.
It's a very fundamental concept, and is used
to describe a lot of phenomenon, including
physical and chemical phenomena.
And, also a lot of chapters we will learn
further on such as limits, derivatives, continuity
or be it any other chapter in mathematics,
knowing functions is very important.
It is a very fundamental chapter.
It has various definitions, and so a lot of
use for the next topics that you will learn.
So, we will start with an intuitive definition
of functions.
Something that we will try to understand using
examples, and then we will try to go into
a more mathematically precise definition.
Functions are used to describe, a special
relation
between two variables.
So, here the word "relation" is a mathematical
concept that we will understand later; but
this (functions) is a very intuitive concept.
We have two variables of interest, and we
are trying to define what is the relationship
between them.
And, that is something which is important
in a lot of places, because you always have
something such as an input to a system and
an output to a system and you want to figure
out what the system is doing.
Functions come in handy at that place a lot.
This is a very intutitive description of functions.
In order to define it for our use, we ... mathematicians
... use different types of descriptors for
functions.
Typically, functions are described using a
graph, a rule or an equation.
Now, we will see how this is done.
When you have two variables either you can
drive a graph, a plot OR you can have a very
intuitive rule which you can easily describe
OR at times as we will see more and more we
will be using equations to describe a function.
So, let's begin with a very simple example.
We will take life of a typical student who
is studying for an exam and going to school.
We want to figure out who his or her day goes.
Let's call the student Sonu, and we want to
find out how Sonu's day went.
And, the variable that we are interested in
is "How far Sonu is from home?"
Variable 1 is time.
Variable 2 will be
Sonu's distance from home.
Now, let's go to the first definition that
we wrote.
So, our first description for function is
that function is a "special" relation between
two variables.
And, here what we have are two varibles of
interest - one is "time of the day" and (the
other is) "how far Sonu is from the home."
So, let's try to make plot for a typical day.
I will try to remember how my school days
were, and try to make a plot based on that.
On x-axis I will draw time of day, and on
y-axis I will draw distance from home.
We will try time count from midnight, and
in 24-hour format.
A
day has 24 hours.
And, then we want to figure out how the day
went.
In morning, Sonu was home till 6 o'clock.
Then he when to school, so the distance was
how much farther the school was.
He was at school till roughly 2pm, which is
14 hours.
Then let's say he goes to a friends place,
and spends some time there.
Then he comes back home, and spends the rest
of the time at home.
So, here we see very intuitively we can describe
the relationship between two variables using
a plot.
This plot is essentially describing a function
of where Sonu is throughout the day - how
far Sonu is from his home - throughout the
day with respect to time of the day.
Similarlt, we can draw such graphs or such
relations for different variables.
So, taking an example from physics.
Let's say we want to study a similar thing
for an object which is moving with a constant
velocity.
So, let's take another example.
And if we want to draw a plot of distance
of this object from the starting point it
will be something very similar to this.
The nature of the graph will be different,
but essentially we are plotting similar things.
Variable one will be time.
And, variable two will be distance from start.
And (from physics) we know if an object is
moving with a constant velocity ... it can
be described by an equation.
Let's say we denote the variable two as 'd',
and this is described by 't'.
And let's say that the speed is one which
is given.
This is an example where we described the
function as an equation.
So, we saw that a function can be described
by a graph, a rule.
At first the rule was where you are from home.
Or it could be a rule like object moving with
a constant speed.
At times we also use equations.
And, they are interchangeable.
We can write this rule as an equation and
this equation as a graph.
This is how distance varies with time.
These are some examples of function, which
occur in day to day activities.
And in these examples we saw that function's
input was time, but thay doesn't have to be
the case.
Functions can have different notions of variable
one and variable two depending on the application.
Another interesting way to look at function
is as an input output relation.
Here, in the examples that we studied we had
two variables.
We can see them as a relation between input
which goes through the function and out comes
the output.
So, in example 1 input was time of day.
And, output was distance from home.
Similarly, in example two the input was time
in hours and output was distance from starting
location.
So, we have seen multiple ways of intuitively
describing a function.
Either it could be a special relation between
two variables, it could be described using
a graph, rule or equation ...
It could be thought of as a system which converts
an input to an output.
And whenever we have anything of this sort,
we can use functions to describe it.
Once we have these functions, they are pretty
useful and they can be manipulated to figure
out to find out properties of a system.
So far, we have seen a few examples.
Now, I would request you to take some time
to think about other functions that you encounter
in daily life.
For those of who you like sports, you can
think of something in cricket.
Your favorite hits a ball and you want to
figure out how fast the ball is moving.
So, you can have time after which the ball
was hit and the speed of the ball.
It does not necessarily have to be speed or
time, it can be something all together different.
Let's say you are going from Bombay to Delhi,
and the number of passangers change at each
station.
Based on the distance from Mumbai, you can
figure out the number of passangers in the
train.
In the train example, distance is the input
variable or the variable 1.
And output variable is number of passengers.
And similarly you can find other functions
in your day to day activities.
They occur in various physical and chemical
phenomena.
So, a lot of things that you are learning
in physics and chemistry - functions are also
useful there to describe those phenomena.
Again, take some time to think about examples
of functions.
Also, one thing that is important to see here
is what makes variable one go on the x axis
and variable two on y.
Is it possible to flip the variables on the
graph?
Why is variable one on the x axis and variable
two on the y axis?
One reason that you could think of is that
variable one is input and variable two is
the output; but there are other reasons that
we will see as we go ahead.
This was a very intuitive definition of function,
now let's study it from a mathemaically precise
perspective.
For that we will go back to our orginial statement
- "functions are used to describe special
relation between two variables.
"
Here we have a few mathematical terms, we
have relations and w have variables.
We will try to see how they relate to the
mathematical concepts that we already know.
One thing that we have already learnt is sets.
Sets are a collection of items.
So, let's say we have sets A and B.
A and B could be any sets of objects of interest.
Let's denote elements of A with small a, and
that of set B with small b.
Once we have these sets, we have variables
from those sets.
Whenever there is any relationship between
these variables, we can define them using
certain mathematical constructs.
One construct is the Cartesian products of
two sets.
So, a Cartesian products of two sets A, B
is given by A cross B. And, it includes all
the elements a comma b.
Let's say A has two variables a1 and a2.
And, set B has one variable b1.
Then, A cross B will have two variables (a1,b1)
and (a2,b2)
(cut near )
But, if set B had another variable b2.
Then the total variables will be four.
Cartesian products of two sets includes number
of elements of set A multiplied by number
of elements of set B. T
This is a very big set, and a Relation is
defined as a subset of the Cartesian product.
So, let's say for some reason you are only
interested in the subset of the Cartesian
product set.
We call it by R.
R let's say has (a1, b1) and (a2, b2).
Any subset of the cartesian product is a relation.
Now, that we
have defined the important concepts that we
need for the precise defintion of fucntions,...
we will see in the next lecture how we combine
sets, cartesian products and relations - specifically
relations to figure out what is special about
functions.